[Music]
on today's show we talked to a man who's
having money fights with his wife that
may not be about money we talked to a
man who was married for 30 years got
divorced and he's found his true love
and he's nervous to get remarried we
talked to a woman who's sitting on a
giant family secret and she doesn't know
what to do stay tuned
[Music]
right attention what's up this is john
with the dr john deloney's show
man i'm so glad you're with us
talking about mental health
relationships family
pets
pet parents we're talking about
everything and everybody we're so glad
you're here if you want to be on the
show give me a shout at 1-844-693-3291
or go to johndaloni.com
ask and james
hey real quick before we talk about this
austin is sitting in for kelly today
which is so great
my hope is that when you call
and they're expecting kelly and you're
like hello this is austin
that they don't hear that part and they
just think wow kelly does not sound like
i thought she was gonna sound that would
be really fantastic and her beard looks
different than yours that's fantastic um
okay so the questions for humans cards
these cards
they have
lost their minds and if you listen to
this podcast you know i hate selling
stuff i just don't like selling stuff
these have gone bananas and the feedback
has been so great
the uh
just please help us be able to talk to
our families okay so real quick james
i'm going to pull a card out this is the
one for couples since we're basically
married and i'm just gonna pull out a
random one
and um you're gonna answer it this is
questions for humans for couples
huh didn't expect this one
james what's your favorite rap song and
what are some of the lyrics
you've asked me this before and i'm
terrible at this question but i you
answer that like a true spouse so i'll
go to the next one no no that's fine um
i mean the first one that comes to mind
is lose yourself eminem
because
it's kind of
i guess it's a dad it's kind of like
there's a clean version of this one and
it kind of like is a good hype song for
you know going to like the basketball
game to listen to with my my
eight-year-old do you look at your old
and say you only get one shot do not
miss your chance to blow opportunity
knocks once
i start i kind of say that as like the
beat is fading in of the real song but
no i mean eminem is incredible
not only his writing but like his flow
and so i'll go with that it's a little
pedestrian but i'll own that all right
all right um
would you rather have to sing everything
you say out loud or always speak in
rhymes if you had one or the other
both of those things i think give you
hemorrhoids that's so great no actually
like being a being kind of a closet
songwriter i think the rhyming thing
would be fun just to speak in rhymes all
the time yeah give us an example
well
i don't love answering these questions
and you kind of bought yourself into a
corner with that one as well just said
orange
i'll get back to you on that wow so you
now you all know what it's like being
married to james just a real
real
box of farts all right let's go to
johnny in chicago what's up brother
johnny how are we doing
uh good thank you for taking my call you
got it man thanks for calling what's up
how can i help
well my wife and i are not entirely on
the same page financially
we started following the baby steps
last year uh in november it's causing a
lot of fights she's very davis
um it's hard to
discuss anything with money she gets
irritated very quickly
um
i know we need marriage counseling we've
been married 22 years
there are some issues that are
um that have to be addressed um but as
far as these baby steps you know i'm not
i just don't feel willing to take on any
more debt we we're about 169 000 in debt
mostly student loans
um and i'm not worried that we can't pay
this off we can be done with this in two
to three years easy we make really good
money but uh she's not fully on board
and she wants to try to buy a house soon
that's not getting into that kind of
debt yeah
so for people listening baby steps
talking about
dave ramsey who's my friend he's my boss
too um
the get out of debt plan um
and
johnny and your wife been married 22
years
what made you decide like what made you
look in the mirror and go whoa we owe
169
000 we got to get out of this thing what
what when did you discover that um well
i i i'm almost 50. okay and i have a
chronic health issue
nothing that seems that's going to take
my life early but it's an expensive
medication
and you know i have children and um i
you know i just want to leave things in
order uh what do you do for like family
and stuff
um i'm in health club i'll leave it a
thought
i don't want to say too much that's all
good my wife is also in healthcare we
combined make about uh just under 200
000 a year okay
um
this has nothing to do with money
you know that
yes i do okay i do
yeah
the main thing i wanted to ask is i know
we need a marriage counselor but my
question is if most people are normal
a marriage counselor might be normal too
right
and i don't want him pacifying some of
the things we're trying to accomplish
financially you know yeah it's it's a
it's not about money dude yeah there's a
power
problem in your marriage
there's a strength a lack of connection
there's a lack of common purpose
you all are at war and money is the
battleground right now
but a counselors
they don't the counselors shouldn't care
what your goals are they should care
that you know what your goals are and
i'm going to help you connect with one
another as you all achieve these goals
whatever they happen to be
and
your wife
there's a lack of vision here
there's a
you have different fears than she does
and
often i hear and i don't want to over
gender this but often i hear
men try to solve a problem like here's a
debt problem we need to have a plan to
get out of that problem and you need to
whoever you is kids spouse whoever you
need to follow this plan
and i got somebody else on the other
side of that thing saying
i want to be safe
i am scared of you i'm tired of you
walking and telling me how i'm going to
do my life because i'm smart too
and
i'm going to i'll end up putting my
heels in the ground over this issue
because it's not about the money it's
about i'm sick of you just dragging us
around with whatever new plan new idea
new whatever i may be way out to lunch
here man but
this has nothing to do with money this
has to do with common shared vision
i agree what
you said you want to leave your family
with things in order that you have a
chronic health issue that's expensive
and so you feel this pressure to set up
your
family so far you've told me your wife
she went she wants a home
so y'all got two competing things here
you want safety and for you safety looks
like x and she wants safety and safety
looks like why
and then what you got to do here brother
is
stop flexing and stop being like this is
the way it's gotta be and more say
like
what are we gonna i'm almost you're 50
almost 50.
yeah like what's it gonna look like when
we're 16 let's reverse engineer that
back
and you telling her
not we gotta get out of debt we gotta
it's this debt scares me
that i'm gonna leave you i'm gonna die
and i'm gonna leave you with this and i
can't be a part of that
yeah you know john the difficulty i have
is i i'm a very
um
i'm type of person that i like to talk
you like to get into details yep i'm
always inviting her to have these
conversations these deep conversations
because that's just my personality
that's right okay i never tell her what
to do at all i say let's let's get
together and talk about it let's unwrap
this
but this is just my own opinion here i
believe she has very low
emotional iq and she has anger issues so
if i even broach any topic of anything
to try to better either our
relationships money whatever it is
she gets very defensive and very upset
and if i don't let it go after a minute
or two she'll resort to name calling
things of this nature okay that's fair
so it's very hard to
even to to bring up like the last few
days i've been struggling thinking how
am i gonna suggest we go see a marriage
counselor she's gonna say nothing's
wrong or you're the problem or
you know so i even have a problem with
that
you
so
to control what you can control
you're the only per you go see a
counselor
and here's if i'm you here's exactly
what i would say to my wife
i would say
i
i have for some reason i have created a
world where you don't feel safe having a
deep conversation with me
i have not created a world where my wife
feels safe planning for the future
together
and i am not able to fully articulate
how terrified and scared i am of all
this debt
and i'm gonna go see a counselor so i
can learn some new language
because i'm not doing a good job
communicating how much i love you and
how terrified i am for our future
and the future of our kids
and here's the thing brother that's
going to feel like you're caving in like
i'm submitting i'm tapping out
yeah dude you got to get over that's ego
crap talking
all
and otherwise you're going to try to
force your like what's the right thing
to say to her you've already answered
that question there's nothing you can
say to her you already know what that is
what's going to happen and so
you can make yourself stone crazy
both psychologically and biochemically
you're going to i feel that yeah your
blood pressure going to go up you're
going to have just
adrenaline and cortisol pulsing through
your veins all day every day your brain
is going to be anxious and anxious and
anxious until it finally shuts off and
you're going to go into a season of
depressing and then you're going to go
back up to anxiety over and over again
you can do all that
or you can make peace with i know what
she's going to say period now what now
what do i do
now i'm going to take care of me
and i'm gonna make sure that when
i'm ready to have this hard conversation
i'm gonna be all in
okay
and
it is fair to say we're not taking on
any more debt right now
that
that becomes a boundary issue
yeah yeah that's that's that's going to
be hard
it is it is and you may it meant your
house may become hell over it
but at some point
she already drew that she already drew
the line in the sand she said if come
next year
uh we don't get a house that she would
eat and buy a house on her own okay so
do you listen your your
this has nothing to do with money
yeah
and how long have you all been married
22 years together 25.
there's man i'm telling you there's
something else here big
yeah
and my guess is she has told you over
and over for year after year after year
of a thing she wants of a thing she's
interested in
of a
and she finally says enough's enough and
here's the deal man
you gotta lean up she just put a
boundary down
yeah and either she's she's bluffing
you're gonna call that bluff
um
because what i heard her say is i'm
leaving you
yeah um you know the
we had a house but because of my health
issue i had to change careers yep make
adjustments for it so we sold our house
and we downgraded and that was hard
because we were there for about 15 years
yeah she lost her home she lost her
community and yep she said for better or
worse
now she's getting to find out what worse
is like and here's where this is gonna
be really hard man
sometimes people leave people with
chronic health conditions
yeah yeah is that happening to you
um
no i don't the the health issue isn't
such that that she would leave over that
no no it's not it may not be the health
issue but it's the peripheral life that
we all lead now
we can't go on this vacation because i
got to have this medication or i got to
sleep this much or we got to sell this
house and live in an apartment and
it may be that i don't want that life
yeah we were we've been renting for
about three years and she knew that it
was gonna just be um
for about
five years until our son finished uh
high school and
um
you know we would just slowly save but
then that's in that process i discovered
dave i learned the faster way to get at
that yep so i you know i try to invite
her into it try to share with her i
don't make her do it i say you know we
got to do this together
and so she's going to only do so much so
so i want you to not just focus on doing
this plan together
yeah i want you all to focus on doing
the rest of your life together
and what is our new reality
who are we going to be when our son goes
to college
is living in chicago our place for the
rest of our lives could we go do health
care in another city that's got better
um that's got a better cost of living
that the pace is different that we can
get a house sooner or
here's here's a path to a home
if we work like crazy and work overtime
like bonkers
we can be out of debt in 18 months
and then we get one more year of saving
saving saving and then we're gonna go
buy a house
but here's the path to where we want to
go and here's the right smart way to do
it
and by the way buying a house right now
over 170 000 in debt in the most bonkers
housing market of our lifetimes is
clinically insane
clinically insane don't do it
but hear me say brother it's not about
the plan this isn't about money
this is about a wife that says i'm about
i had enough of you
for whatever reason
i've about had enough of this
interaction
and i'm drawing a big line right here
and you can only control you
so i want you to tell her dude i'm sorry
i for some reason i haven't made you
safe
i've made you feel safe i've made you
feel loved haven't made you feel heard
i'm gonna go see a counselor i would
love it if you join me i would love it
if you join me
because we got 10 15 20 30 years left
together 40 years left together and i
want them to be amazing
and something i'm bringing to the table
isn't working
and she says forget you nothing wrong
great cool awesome
i'm gonna go for me
i'm gonna go for us
it's the best you can do my brother
control your thoughts and your behaviors
and your actions that's about it
we're rooting for you my man
hey uh austin stay on the line johnny
we're gonna give you a
free year subscription to ramsayplus
that's all the financial piece classes
that is all of
the videos all every it's the every
dollar app i'm gonna give it to you for
free for a year this is an expensive
gift merry christmas
it's gonna give you all the stuff but
by taking this you promise you will go
call a counselor for you you'll go deal
with you
okay
merry christmas we're we're rooting for
you brother we'll be right back on the
dr john dolone's show
hey good folks and friends and listeners
to the dr john deloney show
the world is bonkers right we all know
this and one of the most common
questions i get is how do i find a
counselor in the chaos i've reached out
and there's a six month waiting list or
i can't afford it or they only take
insurance or i can't get off work and
time to go see somebody and it's way
across town what do i do because i want
help with my anxiety my depression my
relationships are hanging on by a thread
i want to be a better mom i gotta
process this trauma that happened to me
when i was a kid
where do i find a counselor so i
partnered with better help because
betterhelp is customized online therapy
that offers video phone even live chat
sessions so you don't even have to look
at your therapist when you're talking to
them if you don't want to i've taken
away all your excuses and it's more
affordable than in-person therapy and
these are real licensed therapists if
you reach out to them you will be
talking to somebody within 48 hours dr
john dolone show listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
please reach out if you need help that's
betterhelp.com
all right we are back
in black
that's a great song james great song
played with
gibson's let's go to ken in spokane
what's up ken how we doing
hey dr john thanks for taking my call i
appreciate you and your team's work that
you guys do
thank you so much i appreciate me not so
much my team but just kidding they're
awesome they're incredible man hey thank
you so much i'm glad you're in our gang
ken what's up man how can i help
well i i'm in a undecisive part of life
me too man let's do this
okay so um i recently divorced well
about three years ago now my divorce was
final for almost 30 years of marriage to
the day of the divorce actually hey
let's just stop for something um
okay that's a lot
that's a death that's a death i mean
that's a heavy loss what happened after
30 years
well it got real crazy towards the end
basically my my ex
struggled with things in her life
she
hid for years that she was
bisexual
and hid that i just thought she was a
farm girl you know
and that sort of thing and she hid that
for years
and then about five years before the
divorce
she developed breast cancer so we went
through the
that she made it out of the other end we
did
good there
things really changed with the
medications for treatment you know and
radiation and
and i don't know if near-death
experience brought the uh the hidden
uh
thing with her out after that you know
unlike a life change deal that made her
switch to wanting to come out and and go
that direction yeah
uh so there was a lot of uh maybe she
got to the end just said i'm not hiding
anymore this is gonna be the way this is
like life's too short or whatever yeah
yeah yeah so did she leave you for a
woman does she leave you and say hey
this is going to be who i am and you can
be in her i mean how did that end yes
yes so she yeah so she
was secretive and started seeing uh a
couple actually yeah
so she was cheating this is so this
isn't this is less about sexuality this
is infidelity she's cheating on you
right yeah and
her rationale was it's not cheating
because it's with a lady and not a guy
you know all kinds of different things
okay gotcha cheating is cheating
so okay
okay so
sorry go ahead go ahead
i'm a fixer so i was doing everything to
save my marriage you know i got married
in front of god and it was for better
for worse so yeah
i battled and tried to save for
a long time and i think i sacrificed
myself along the process yeah absolutely
yeah
it sounds like there was two hurting
people
trying to heal each other and themselves
at the same time so that's a hard
situation man
and so
30 years
you get to the end and all of a sudden
whoa and then you met somebody new
yeah i actually went to kindergarten
together um when we were young yeah
so you're telling me there's a chance
all right
wow okay how'd y'all reconnect the
internets
yeah so i i was finalizing the divorce
and selling of the house
the exit moved away and took a different
position a different job and i was left
with
selling the property and you know
dividing the assets and that sort of
thing and and going through it
which she never wanted me to do
and she wanted to have a kind of a
double life so to speak and it wasn't
going to work for me or her um
but yeah so she reached out to me and
and i think she could kind of see that i
may have been going through some she got
an indication or a feeling um she was
volunteering at a a boys camp
as a nurse and um
she reached out and said hey is this the
guy that we went to school together
lived next door to me and and i said i
said yeah and then we just started
connecting and next door neighbors it's
like dawson's creek man this is
incredible okay so fast forward it's
been a couple years now you say three
years
yeah we're just we're approaching three
years now we've been dating for about
two
so fun good for you you know the whole
divorce with the x took five years to
kind of process wow everything out it
was a slow
trudge but yeah so we're dating but now
i'm
you know i'm like you know this gal is
amazing you know and and uh we've done
some things together travel with some
friends and things like that
and uh
you know she is divorced years prior uh
quite a few years prior than me and of
course all of our kids are gone out of
the house
so i'm like you know i've had some of
some of our friends say gosh you're
going to marry this guy you're going to
put a ring on her finger and all this
stuff
you know yeah she's amazing and then i
tiny little silly things you know and
everyone has those
glitches you know and uh myself included
and it's like in the back of my head i'm
like is this a red flag because i think
i didn't see so many in my first
marriage and i'm having a hard time
putting that baggage down
and looking at this new and it's
starting to come up in the back of my
head and i'm like
what am i waiting for um
but i'm so
cautious of messing it up yeah yeah so
i'm undecisive um i've talked about this
i talked about this about a year ago a
lot when we had several calls
in similar calls about infidelity
and
i think
one of the
hardest things if not the hardest thing
when somebody cheats on you
there is the obvious breach you brought
somebody else into this relationship you
violated a core covenant that we agreed
we were in this together
that's huge that's a that's a major like
the ground you're walking on is
fractured it's unstable
but i think equal
maybe if not worse long-term damage
is what you're experiencing
which is you lose trust in kin
how in the world did i miss this for so
long or
most of the time
i knew something was up and i didn't say
anything
and
people
will heal from the violation they can
they can outsource it this person made
those choices to cheat on me with
somebody else and i got to live with
that
and they made choices i can be at peace
with the fact that somebody else made
choices that hurt me
but what's really hard to heal from is i
don't trust me anymore
and your brain when you are out of trust
your brain takes over and here's what
your sweet brain is doing for you
because it loves you ken
it is looking for every possible threat
because i'm not it's not doing that
again
it's not going through five years of
hell because it almost killed us last
time i'm not doing that again
so this is just your body your biology
remembering trauma and saying whoa whoa
what are you doing what do you do you
know what i mean
it feels you getting back on the same
roller coaster that almost killed you
last time
it doesn't mean every roller coaster is
unsafe in fact the opposite most roller
coasters are great but it almost killed
you once and your body remembers and so
i want to hear you you'd hear me sick in
you're not crazy
your body's doing exactly what it should
be doing which is trying to look out for
you
the real question you've got to get to
is
is she the right is she right for me
have you been on
uh have you been healing
do you trust ken
and more importantly do you trust her
so answer that for me is this right
i definitely trust her okay um
does she know that you have that your
body's
she knows you've got apprehension does
she know how bad you felt burned
yeah i think so i think i think she does
because let's let's let's own this you
walked through
cancer with somebody
you walked through somebody who almost
died
you wept with her you held her
throughout the night you
went to appointments with her
you figured out insurance and bills and
all stuff y'all went through stuff
together and then on the other side she
said
you're not my guy
have you fully grieved that because that
sucks
yeah it was it was tough and then to
turn around and
go through years of
her infidelity thinking that okay this
is a phase and she's going to come back
around yeah and be that same person she
never was and then i had to
had had to file the divorce for me yeah
and uh she had a great setup man she's
got somebody's gonna ride out cancer
with her and then she can go
have her romantic flings with other
places she had a perfect setup going
yeah i mean even her own mother told me
what are you doing you know she's having
her cake and eating it too and you're
sitting here while she's doing things
that are wrong yeah
and yeah and uh and i i went to a
counselor i did do that and i walked
through that process with the counselor
she was amazing good good good good i'm
proud of you really that's good and so
here
i i just want you to respect your body
and so when i'm innocent and i haven't
been through what you've been through
what you've been through is brutal i
don't want you to underestimate the
trauma and sometimes when we live and
even we live things
and we
because we're living them
it's not as headline it's not
sensational it's not quote unquote over
there it's us in the middle of it and we
don't fully recognize the trauma that
our body took on for us and your body's
been through a lot
and now
your heart fell in love and your brain
is going oh
i know this script i know this story
and so
bringing that into
acknowledging it oh there's my body
pointing out a flaw and you being able
to go
thank you for trying to take care of me
but i'm good now because this one's
awesome she's awesome
and you begin to let your brain know i'm
in control i'm good i'm getting back on
this roller coaster on purpose because
it's super fun it's gonna be amazing and
we're gonna get whipped around a little
bit like all roller coasters but it's
gonna be a blast and then eventually
your body goes cool you're driving we're
back but you gotta practice that
um
so i'm kind of i'm smiling here
do you love this this woman
i do
yeah
so
let yourself say it out loud
do you want to marry her
i do
is that scaring you in my head it seems
like yes it absolutely because i'm
afraid of messing it up
because you think you messed up the last
one
well i couldn't fix it i think that's
what i can't get out of my head and i
and i
you know i'm being a fixer it was
totally against who i am you know well
ken
you didn't break your last marriage
you didn't break it
and the fact that you couldn't quote
unquote save something that you couldn't
save anyway
doesn't mean you're a failure doesn't
mean you screwed up
i need you to let that go put that down
because you're carrying this narrative
that if you had just said the right
thing or done the right thing that maybe
she would have stayed attracted to you
maybe she
it wasn't gonna happen
and you gotta set that down because
you've got too much life left and you've
got an amazing woman on the other side
of this thing
waiting for full ken and what i want you
to do is love ken as much as this new
woman loves ken
does she love you
yes absolutely he tells me constantly
chose me
and constantly too
dude can i tell you something you're
worth being loved and you're worth
laughing
i have a great friend she
she's about probably 15 or 20 years
older than me she had a long-term
relationship and
kids were grown and found out there was
some infidelity they got divorced and
then it was a brutal divorce and then
shortly thereafter
um her ex got sick and passed away
and
then she got remarried years later and i
was asking her about this process and
she said i built a life with somebody
we raised kids
created a home
i got remarried
because i loved this person
and we were gonna have as much fun as
humanly possible until my days are over
and that subtle shift was such a
powerful statement for me
and how old are you
um almost 55.
dude
you're a little over halfway
and you've got somebody that's gonna get
old and wrinkly and ride or die with you
man and y'all can slide into the end of
this thing with no tread left on your
tires
i need you to hear that you're worth
that
do you believe me
i do yeah
all right
say these words
ken's worth loving again
ken toward 11 again
you just said that all weird like i was
telling you about taxes say ken's worth
loving again i want you to mean it
ken's worth loving again hell yeah dude
yeah ken
now you don't have to marry this girl
but i think you should i think it'd be
awesome
i think you're going to man and it
should be weird and it should be
uncomfortable and it's all still all
right
the only thing i can't i'm going to ask
you to not do is don't keep secrets from
your new wife
when you feel uncomfortable you all come
up with a signal like ah i'm trying to
get nervous
ah
but i love you
and here's what i want you to do when
you get engaged i want you to send me a
picture of that ring on her finger
don't you send me a picture of the
wedding
you are probably gonna get some weird
doodle dog or something send me a
picture of that
do not get
one of those motorcycle tricycles
you're 55 but you're not
walking dead
and dude i'm excited for you ken i'm
excited for you brother i'm excited for
you
everything in your body is trying to do
is just love you and take care of you
man
you gotta tell your body thank you thank
you thank you
maybe do this i say this every single
show almost i want you to write yourself
a letter dear ken
dear ken
go back and walk through here's what it
was like loving somebody through cancer
here's what it's like finding out that
she was cheating on me here's what it
was like trying to hold everything
together
here's what it's like the heartbreak of
divorce of it when it was all over
here's what that grief was like
and then there's a period at the end of
that sentence and then i want you to
turn the page and i want you to then
write and now what
and here's what my life's gonna be i
found a great girl that i've known since
we are next door neighbors dawson's
creek i don't want to wait and we're
going forward with whatever minutes and
hours we got left we're gonna have the
most fun and we're gonna do it together
you deserve a kin you're worth it
thank you so much for the call we'll be
right back on the dr john delaney show
one of the most common questions folks
ask me is what they should do when
anxiety or panic strikes you know like a
lightning bolt and i've been helping
folks 101 for years but i wanted to
create something that everyone could use
anywhere at any time so i created a free
guided meditation and it's not really a
meditation but really just me walking
with you through your anxiety alarms
from start to finish and i'll guide you
through a breathing exercise show you
how to lean in listen and head towards
healing it's free and for everyone even
you tough hard chargers right you can
download this guided meditation today
for free at johndeloney.com
all right let's take one more call let's
go to
marie in cleveland ohio what's up marie
how we doing
i'm great thank you so much for taking
my call are you a baker mayfield fan
a what
a baker mayfield fan
i don't i don't know what that is
listen
i'm married but i kind of love you i'm
glad you don't know who that is that's
the quarterback of the cleveland browns
oh not a huge fan so good for uh
shout out shout out way to go marie
i don't know any like sports references
as well at all and that makes you a
great person all right so what's up how
can i help
um thank you thank you just amazing to
be able to talk to you so thank you so
much it is more amazing to be talking to
you so what's up
the past month and a half i've been
listening to your show and it's just
been mind-blowing how amazing it's been
for me so wow thank you so much
um so my sister uh we are
um the two oldest of five kids and she
is my uh she's two years older than me
and she is not my biological sister
yeah we have different dads
and she does not know it
oh
hi
how does she not know
um so
my mom um met my dad and i think she was
only uh maybe a month or two pregnant
and then they got married um that next
summer um a month after my sister was
born
and
i've know i've known for about 10 years
my mom told me when i was in my early
20s and
she just
she never told her
and
family knows even some close friends
know
god why would your mom do that to you
i don't
i don't know i think that she felt that
i was probably mature enough to be able
to handle it oh my gosh this is the
worst
gosh
that's the meanest thing
that's so mean is your does your
does your dad know
that yes
so your sweet sister is just bee-bopping
through life hugging on dad and
everybody knows
but her
yes
my mom told me i cried and she's like
why are you crying and i said i'm just
thinking that if you just were you
telling me about this about me i thought
i would be heartbroken
yes and did you do my first question
would have been was dad my dad
yeah and then she would have said well
of course honey and then you would have
said
how do i how do i
trust anything is santa claus real
you're going to tell me that too
god almighty what an evil thing to do to
a young 20 year old sister so
you've are you close with your older
sister
so no um
it's getting a little bit better but
i've recently been in counseling
and counseling has
basically unveiled my childhood to me
i thought that i was this
super mature
and
helpful and um
the golden child basically is kind of my
childhood when i was actually as my
counselor called it a parentified child
and um my sister was defiant and she was
hard and it was it was really
it was really really difficult okay can
i give you some context for that yes
i would be willing to bet
my truck and let's be clear it's not
nice
so it's not a huge win if anybody picks
up the other side of that bet
your sister was not wanted in this new
marriage
she was a daily reminder to a newlywed
couple
that mom slept with some other dude and
got knocked up
and your dad
as part of the deal had to raise
somebody else's daughter and all of that
stress and all of that stuff
and your sister absorbed every second of
it
i
is that fair
it's hard it's hard for me to have a
compassion
a clear understanding because i
obviously did not understand my
childhood very well while i was going
through it
um and
so i i
saw my dad as a wonderful dad
and somebody who took care of his family
and and loved my mom and loved my sister
so
i don't want to think of them as
being malicious towards my sister in any
kind of way i don't think
i don't think malicious is the right way
okay i
the research on adhd right now says a
lot of that begins in utero with
maternal stress
just finding out i'm pregnant and i
had a one night stand with somebody and
i love this new guy and is he gonna love
me and how am i going to have this baby
and will you
all that stuff
just pulses through this human being
and even if
so your description of your dad is
i'm assuming i'm not let's talk bad
about him i'm just talking reality
yeah you were his baby
you were the one
you were his firstborn
and i'm not saying he's worse he did a
noble thing he's probably an incredible
dad loved
but there is a gap there is a difference
it's kind of like i walk into a room i'm
a big guy
i'm 6'2 195. i'm a big guy i walk into a
room and i'm like everybody's cool here
and then my friend george is like how
big is george 411 102 he's a little guy
he experiences that room differently
than me
yeah and i can be like no dude it's just
like this can you not see and he's like
yeah you're two feet taller your
your view is different
both of our realities are true
but i i want to always lean over and say
lean in lean over that's funny he is
short but i want to lean into
like what is your reality here's mine
all i have to say is i don't want to get
into your sister situation um other than
i'm glad glad glad you got in you're
seeing somebody
and let that be about illumination not
about blame is that fair
yes okay cool
okay so i just don't know if i should
if it's been i've known for like i think
it's been at least 10 years and my and
now my younger brothers they know and i
just don't
okay this makes it a little more
complicated so she had three children
and my parents are raising two of them
and my husband and i are raising her
third child we've had him from the
moment he was born we brought him home
from the hospital we were there for his
birth
and
the reason the whole should i tell her
comes up is because my son will know
i'm going to be 100 honest with him and
we're gonna have trust and we're gonna
have
you know clarity about who he is
and
i just can see him one day telling my
sister well no you know he's not
actually my biological grandfather and
they're blowing up my sister's world
so let me be super clear your sister's
world has been blown up
it has been blown up since the day she
came home and was told that somebody
else was her
dad yeah
every bit of it has been blown up
and so the only thing left to do
is to help with the healing process
let me put it this way this conversation
is happening
whether it happens today or in five
years or in ten years it's happening
yes
and the
let me let me just tell you personally i
will not keep immediate secrets for
family
so if anybody in my family were to call
and say hey i just got to tell you this
don't tell i was to stop him and say i'm
not good i'm not going to hear that i
don't know what you're about to say but
i'm not keeping secrets from my family
i'm not going to be the big secret
keeper because it kills me
it puts my integrity on the line you
hand me one of your bricks and expect me
to carry it forever you've been carrying
this for 10 years
and every time your relationship gets a
little bit closer with your sister this
big looming thing is there and here's
the thing
she feels that
yeah she doesn't know what it is and so
what she does she blames herself or she
blames you
she either says i'm still not enough
she's still the golden child she's still
the great because there's that little
gap and kids feel it
you've heard that saying like when
you're driving and you can just turn
your wheel one degree and the whole car
eventually turns in a circle
just that one little feeling as a young
kid that dad likes her more than me what
is it about me do i not look right do i
not smell right do i not hug right what
is it
and i just feel like telling that that's
going to confirm those things to her and
that's but
here's the thing she's been running for
how old is she 35 40 yeah she's 35.
for 35 years she thought it was her
she thought she was the defect
yeah yeah and what you may give yes this
thing's going to go nuclear make no
mistake has she been an
addict um
no i'm i i she
um like as far as like drugs go she's
tried to she doesn't like the way they
make her feel i think she has some um
maybe some she's on the autism
spectrum why are you
keeping our kid
motherhood didn't work um and i'm not it
was it feels like forever ago my son is
eight now um but she she tried to raise
her two oldest
girls and
she had a very hard time with it it's
they're both all three kids are from
three different men
and she didn't commit to any kind of
relationship with any of the men and
then when she found out she was pregnant
again um my mom and my dad
um
encouraged her to let them raise her
girls and then she asked my husband and
i um we had a two-year-old at the time
and they asked us if you know we would
raise
him and we were
we were more than happy to do that so
imagine a place you would have to be
to call somebody who you've lived in
their shadow your whole life
and said
will you take my baby
can you even imagine that i can't even
wrap my head around that
yeah and that's what she's had to do so
you've got this woman
who lives in
24 she bathes in shame
and is reaching out for connection every
all i said we tell your sister all day
long here's i think as a as just basic
human dignity she deserves the truth
yeah and i will tell you the
conversation will have be had
it will be
which person's gonna have the courage to
do it and where is this nuclear bomb
going to go off
is it gonna
tell my mom that i'm telling her or if
i'm you i would tell my mom i cannot
keep your lie a secret anymore
i refuse to i won't even say i can't
because that makes it sound like it's
out of my control nope i am making a
grown-up choice
i refuse to keep your lie anymore
and what mom's gonna say is oh you're
gonna blow up everything and the
response is no
you blew it up 35 years ago
yeah and i'm not doing this anymore
because i'm a liar and i refuse to lie
on your behalf any longer i'm not going
to do it i'm teaching young kids about
integrity and doing what's right and we
don't keep secrets in this family and i
love you this is how family treats each
other
but by the way i'm over here with mom
yeah
and i just it's no more and
there will be a nuclear fallout here and
you will sleep better than you've slept
in
10 years
is that fair
yeah
so i would tell my mom
you've got 20 days you've got two 14
days you've got two weeks to have this
conversation
and by the way you will not do this over
text
you'll do an in-person conversation
well we all live in different states hey
this is a conversation you get on an
airplane
yeah
to say 35 years of your life has been a
lie
yeah and your inability to hold a
relationship your inability to feel like
you are worth anything
maybe
because we lied to you
from the day you were born
yeah
yeah that's a get on an airplane that's
i don't have the money figure it out
we're going to do this one in person
and you're going to show up with
pictures here is your real dad here's
his name here's where he lives
and tells me that she doesn't know that
not true when she told me but yeah i got
the kind of indication and feeling that
that wasn't true we found osama bin
laden he can be found
he can be found i think that's what my
mom has always been worried about that
she would just go searching for her
actual face she should when we were her
family
she should go find her dad
yes
yes
she's 35.
who we
protect who are we protecting what has
our protection got us
yeah
we've been trying to protect and look at
the life that's just in ash
she's got three beautiful kids that
don't even live with her anymore
yeah she's got no close relationships
and nobody's drawn the line back to
day one when we lied to her the day she
was born
yeah
and so all this
if you were protecting her and she had a
wonderful four kids and a great partner
and an awesome job as a surgeon and or a
you know she was running a small
business and life was great
and you were like man we gotta tell her
the truth i get i get how hard that
would be you still gotta do the right
thing but i get like we're about to take
a norman rockwell painting and set it on
fire i get that
yeah but y'all are protected it's like
your life isn't like that at all no no
it's like y'all are trying to protect
her from a fire and you put her in the
middle of the fire pit
all right no more fight nobody tell her
that there's fire she's burned to a
crisp she gets it and so i'm telling you
what you already know i
secrets destroy families and by the way
your relationship with your mom is
fractured over this
yes your relationship with your dad is
fractured over this
because you there's a part there's a
little girl in you that doesn't trust
them either
yeah
and you have probably made some
commitments to your kids that i will
never but you got this big one hovering
over and you got to deal with it so i
give mom you got two weeks to do an
in-person conversation or i'm getting on
an airplane and i'm going to fly to be
with my sister and i'm going to have a
hard conversation
real hard okay i can do that okay now
hear me say this goes bad
it goes bad
yeah
and you can send me an email on the
flight home and be like that son of a i
hate to loan that guy i'm telling you it
goes bad
in your soul you know this is right
yes i do yes is your husband with you
uh yes well he's not here with me i know
but is he all in
yes he he and so do my brothers they
understand they they feel like i'm about
to why why am i about to blow up her
world but i agree with you it's already
a mess it's over yeah you're
you are gonna
possibly
give her the first
glimpse of light through the cracks of
her life that she's ever seen
yeah and being able to look her in the
eye and say i need you to hear me say i
you're not crazy
yeah and
she has a right to be
enraged
because for the last 35 years this has
been her fault her problems
and they are she's made bad choices
let's be clear
but my guess is my gut tells me she has
been in search for some for true
connection since the day she was born
and she's been looking over and over and
over and over for it
this might be the first real
conversation she's ever had in her life
marie ever ever ever and god bless you
for having him
but yeah no more secrets no more secrets
no more secrets mom you got seven days
and then i'm getting on a plane
that one's gonna be tough
that one's gonna be tough
i'm glad you're there marie go make that
call
all right as we wrap up today's show man
this is a it's often i found an old 80s
no this is a like a
not 80s metal this is like metal metal
no it's grunge metal grunge metal
off the allison chains dirt record i
liked that record did you like that
record james
i've never listened to a single allison
chain's record wow
austin how would you like a producing
job
could be awesome
songs off the dirt record it's called
them bones and it goes like this it's
not really a happy song
i believe them bones are me and some say
we're born into the grave
and i feel so alone
gonna end up a big old pile of them
bones
yeah as i'm reading this is not a happy
song dust rise right oh on over my
tongue
empty fossil of the new scene
i feel so alone i'm gonna end up a big
old pile of them bones told dude bad
dream come true i lied dead gone under a
red sky
i feel so alone i'm going to end up a
big old pile of them bones i wonder why
all the grunge guys were so sad well i
really wish i'd listened to allison
james now
you're more than a pile of bones america
talk to you soon on the doctor john de
luna show